come on people hit the dance floor have
a good time
why is no one having a good time i
specifically requested it and captain
banned headphones from the office due to
the gina incident
[Music]
maybe you should just call it a day i
can't i've been asked to deliver a toast
here after the funeral a message of
hope
this is what i have so far
pain
[Music]
that's it dog fraud i saw the guy fake
peeking knees
towards the cat you will not win me over
with your use of twas i wasn't trying to
i've only had arlo for a day and a half
but if anything happened to him i would
kill everyone in this room and then
myself
so how'd it go it actually went
surprisingly well
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
honestly this is the best i could have
asked for well remember when you told me
not to burn down the precinct
you burned down the precinct no i had
the fire put out almost immediately this
is a success story in high school i was
voted most appropriate ooh self burn
those are rare
are you really playing the gate card
right now yes queen
anyways i'm gonna go cry in the bathroom
peace out homies
but i'm not in denial i'm in denial i
think we should break up that makes me
feel sad
i'm sad your status is noted wow
dare you detective diaz i am your
superior officer bone what happens in my
bedroom detective is none of your
business bone
hello good sir i'd like your finest
bottle of wine please that will be
sixteen hundred dollars great i'd like
your eight dollarist bottle of wine
please i'm not a thug i'm police okay
the name one law don't kill people
that's on me i set the bar too low
good morning boyle
i have no regrets everything is garbage
i know you find something you care about
it's taken from you
your colleague
your dream job
your mango yogurt
never
love
anything sexy train is leaving a station
check out this caboose later [ __ ]
occupied
all men are at least 30 attracted to me
my mother cried the day i was born
because she knew she would never be
better than me at any given moment i'm
thinking about one thing richard
dreyfuss hunkered over eating dog food i
feel like i'm the paris of people
that's gonna leave a mark give it a
whirl girl all right i'm gonna go cry
vindication
[Music]
i am in
incredible pain
aren't you forgetting something
uh
no pay your bill
damn who raised you
don't eat the burrito
[Music]
look at me
do not
blow this for us
now i'm telling my friend about how you
killed that guy it was for love cool
motive still murder what are you gonna
do annoy him into talking
ha ha
two three four
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
didn't work
q did not work
ladies and gentlemen today is the
greatest day of my life
guess who just got murdered
hi gina linetti the human form of the
100 emoji see charles be myself what
kind of garbage advice is that i hope
you're not telling nikolaj that crap
nikolaj
rules are made to be broken they were
made to be followed nothing is made to
be broken uh pinatas glow sticks karate
boards spaghetti when you have a small
pot rules kind of woman doesn't have an
ax
okay no hard feelings but i hate you not
joking bye you could have died man i
wasn't hurt that badly the doctor said
all my bleeding was internal that's
where the blood's supposed to be
if i die turn my tweets into a book i'm
fine i've decided to stop fighting it
and lean into the fact that i'm an idiot
there she is amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you care to
explain yourself i'm just 70 seconds
late it's not a big deal don't worry
about it santiago you will tell us and
you will tell us
now there's a problem at the bank
hot damn
you